- Nous sommes chez Edaid
Bensoudame dans le sud-ouest
d'Ottawa.
Des branches d'arbre ont
traversé le toit et le plafond.
Les orages violents du 21 mai
ont laissé sa maison dans
un piteux état.
Le père de famille a procédé
à des travaux d'urgence
le lendemain. Il fallait
boucher les trous laissés par
des branches pour éviter
d'autres dégâts.
Toit, murs et plafonds devront
mplacés, sans compter les
dommages causés à la structure.
Des travaux qui pourraient
prendre tout l'été,
selon monsieur Bensoudame.
Mais il devra attendre
avant de commencer les travaux,
parce que le milieu de
la construction est frappé
autre tempête.
PIERRE LAFONTAINE, v-p.
développ. affair. Groupe Raymond
- La disponibilité des
matériaux, c'est terrible
depuis 12-16 mois environ.
- Il y a une demande d'estimés
de plus. Il y a une main-
d'oeuvre qualifiée qui n'est pas
disponible et il y a
une augmentation des coûts. En
fait, c'est la tempête parfaite.
- Son entreprise se spécialise
en développement du bâtimentntnt
au Québec et en Ontario.
Après les orages violents,
les appels ont dou
et on multiplie les réparations
temporaires.
- On avait déja un surplus de
travail et avec la tempête,
on a un surplus de travail
encore, et ces jobs-là, ils ne
se feront pas avant l'automne.
Il y a des toitures qui vont
rester temporairement réparées
durant l'hiver.
- Cet autre entrepreneur ave
aussi que les délais seront plus
longs. Il a reçu 400 appels et
200 demandes en ligne après
les orages.
"Ce n'est plus premier arrivé,
premier servi", explique-t-il.
Son équipe priorise maintenant
les besoins les plus urgents.
De quoi  l'épreuve
la patience des clients.
Ici Rosair,
Radio-Canada, Ott